this program is brought to you by Emory
University the bad news is that in so
far as we're going to be able to
genetically manipulate ourselves it
probably won't be already born adults
who will be able to get some injection
of genes and all of a sudden have these
powers that'll probably be if it ever
happens some way to manipulate embryos
or zygotes so that they can develop from
the beginning with those kinds of powers
the good news is that the way to get
those powers is not through genetic
manipulation anyway and we are creating
really remarkable kinds of technologies
even bio technologies that is ways in
which to create brain computer
interfaces to allow one to work more
seamlessly with prosthetics for example
people who've lost arms are now being
able to use very sophisticated
prosthetic arms that move around through
a variety of different techniques muscle
twitching nervous impulses another thing
that allows them to have great dexterity
with these prosthetics so it's going to
be through some hybridization of organic
and synthetic that will give the people
of the next few decades these powers but
it's not going to be through genetic
mutation
you
the preceding program is
University